buenos días nos acompaña gerardo
peñalver portal el viceministro primero
de exteriores de cuba pero díaz gerardo
cuál es el motivo de su visita y cómo
están las relaciones entre cuba y
francia la relaciones con francia está
en estos momentos un estado yo diría que
excelente ese es motivo precisamente de
que yo haya viajado a parís para dar
continuidad a las consultas políticas
entre nuestras cancillerías que se
desarrollan a nivel de secretario
general del ministerio de europe de
asuntos exteriores de francia nuestro
ministerio de relaciones exteriores a
nivel de viceministros primero
y abordamos con la contraparte francesa
temas de nuestras relaciones bilaterales
de la agenda internacional
en un marco muy constructivo tanto los
proyectos económicos comerciales las
relaciones financieras y de cooperación
así como el diálogo político de nuestras
visiones y enfoques sobre variados temas
de la agenda internacional donde muchos
de ellos tenemos visiones comunes vice
ministro cuba preside actualmente la
conferencia de la onu sobre desarme
fundada en 1979 esto lo llevó a usted a
suiza qué importancia tiene un foro como
este en momentos en que hay una guerra
en europa que ha llevado a un refuerzo
del armamento de varios países incluida
por ejemplo alemania la otan y el envío
de armas a ucrania si efectivamente el
pasado 21 de marzo asumió la presidencia
de la conferencia de desarme estuvimos
en ginebra
efectuamos ahí nuestra intervención a
nombre de cuba para dar inicio en esa
presidencia y alertados en nuestra
intervención en nuestro discurso sobre
los retos que tenemos los desafíos que
tenemos nuestros momentos para
trabajar por el desarme y
específicamente por el desarme nuclear
por eso es una buena noticia que se
hayan reanudado los trabajos de la
conferencia de desarme
con la esperanza de poder contribuir a
avanzar en el camino del desarme general
y específicamente del desarme nuclear en
un momento donde por supuesto está
latente más que
más que hace mucho tiempo el peligro de
una conflagración nuclear tres días
después del inicio de la invasión de
rusia ucrania cuba culpó a eeuu y los
afanes expansionistas de la otan de esta
guerra y declaró que rusia tiene derecho
a defenderse hoy que mueren a diario
civiles que las ciudades están
destruidas que millones de ucranianos
han dejado su país cuba sigue pensando
lo mismo cubo al aumento a la pérdida de
vidas humanas por supuesto y la posición
de nuestro país quedó refrendada
primeramente la declaración del
ministerio de relaciones exteriores y
luego una declaración de gobierno
jugada defiende los principios del
derecho internacional de la carta de las
naciones unidas y abogamos por el no uso
de la fuerza ni la amenaza del uso de la
fuerza en las relaciones internacionales
por lo tanto
estamos a favor de ninguna guerra
el conflicto en ucrania es un conflicto
que tiene impacto
la economía mundial en la paz y la
seguridad internacional por lo tanto
nosotros abogamos por una solución
negociada
política y pacífica sobre todo en ese
sentido reconocemos los esfuerzos que ha
realizado
el gobierno francés y muy especialmente
el presidente manuel macro para mediar
en una posible solución pacífica y
política de ese conflicto yo creo que es
un un gesto de un esfuerzo que se
reconoce no solo en europa sino en
general en el mundo al propio tiempo
cuba ha venido alentando de qué
la posición
específicamente de los eeuu ha conducido
a arrastrado a esa situación que se
podría haber evitado porque yo pienso
que si se busca una paz duradera hay que
buscar la paz para todos y no sólo para
unos pocos hay que buscar fórmulas que
garanticen la soberanía
la seguridad la estabilidad de todos y
no es sólo unos pocos y por eso
sostenemos nuestro criterio aún con
mayor convicción de que está este
conflicto se podría haber evitado si los
eeuu
hubieran reaccionado a las solicitudes
legítimas de garantías de seguridad que
formuló la federación de rusia durante
mucho tiempo de una manera muy ecuánime
y de una manera muy incoherente sin
embargo se hizo caso omiso a estas
solicitudes a estos reclamos y vemos que
ahora estamos la humanidad entera está
sufriendo las consecuencias
un conflicto rusia es uno de los diez
socios comerciales más importantes de
cuba de hecho es una relación
estratégica así ha sido bautizada el
gigante de reestructurado en febrero la
deuda de cuba hasta el año 2027 cuáles
son las consecuencias que está teniendo
justamente el bloqueo contra rusia para
la economía cubana con la
interdependencia de la interconexión que
tiene el mundo y con la globalización
realmente impacta en el mundo entero
este conflicto q vamos como país pequeño
como países desarrollados por supuesto
que de inmediato está empezando a sufrir
las consecuencias del conflicto
nuestra economía una economía muy
abierta por ejemplo uno de los
principales sectores de nuestra economía
es el turismo y el turismo se va viendo
afectado por el conflicto por el cierre
de los espacios aéreos y puede generar
por la situación de inestabilidad donde
la gente normalmente evita viajar
el incremento de los precios
de las materias primas de los metales de
los alimentos y de los combustibles y
también especialmente de los de los
cereales dentro de los alimentos tiene
un efecto también negativo para jugar a
un país importador neto de alimentos y
tiene un impacto en general para nuestra
región también para américa latina y
para el mundo por lo tanto no estamos
ajenos a estas consecuencias que de
punto de vista económico tiene y tendrá
este conflicto en la economía mundial de
hecho en los últimos días hemos visto
colas en las gasolineras cubanas a qué
se debe bueno ustedes saben que cuando
hay un lugar una amenaza de huracán
a uno ve aquí en europa por ejemplo y
así lo ve en eeuu por hablar de dos
economías desarrolladas como la gente
corre a los supermercados y hace grandes
colas y se lleva a todos los productos
de papel sanitario hasta los alimentos
en conserva
este es un efecto psicológico por
supuesto y también yo estaba en europa
pero he podido seguir por las redes
sociales por las noticias que ha habido
grandes colas en el
servicentro
tiene que ver con con el efecto
psicológico del conflicto pero tiene que
ver también con que cuba ha estado
sometida a medidas
crecientes de bloqueo y de sanciones a
las compañías navieras y a los tanqueros
que llevan combustible a cuba porque
cuba solo produce la red de la mitad de
la energía que necesita el combustible
que necesita
en su matriz energética la otra mitad el
otro 50% no importamos y entonces a
veces se nos dificulta encontrar
buques tanqueros navíos para traer los
alimentos y el combustible a cuba por el
recrudecimiento de las sanciones y
desbloqueados de eeuu y eso lo que
explica que con alguna regularidad aún
cuando no exista conflicto armado en el
mundo hay colas de las gasolineras hay
colas en los supermercados finalmente
usted cree que esta crisis puede escalar
un enfrentamiento de rusia con la otan o
una crisis como la del intento de la
rusia soviética
ar misiles en cuba en 1962 bueno es muy
difícil hablar de pronóstico realmente
el mundo
no es una respuesta fácil es algo que
nadie desea y nosotros pensamos que
seguramente primará el sentido común
seguramente primarán los esfuerzos por
evitar una escalada y yo creo que una
gran responsabilidad
para todos incluyendo la otan la unión
europea los estados unidos rusia ucrania
todos son parte de la solución y
nosotros la crisis del año 62 la crisis
de octubre fue una etapa en que el mundo
vivió muy seca de una conflagración
nuclear es algo que la comunidad
internacional no desee
y que pensamos que
podrán prevalecer los los esfuerzos por
llegar a una solución pacífica negociada
del conflicto y que no tengamos que
lamentar ninguna
conflagración de de alcances
impredecibles
yo creo que hay que darle una
oportunidad a la paz y confiemos en que
los políticos
racionales y serán
constructivo para lograr esa esa tan
anhelada paz que todos desean muchas
gracias gerardo peñalver portal por esta
entrevista con france 24 gracias a usted